well it's pretty Mike Freeman does a
great job covering the NFL over a police
report Mike joins me here on the show
let's start with Jared Goff Mike new
coach out there in LA somebody not wed
to Jared Goff wasn't part of the group
that drafted him what what kind of
pressure of any is on Jared Goff this
year well there's a little bit he has to
I mean it's obvious as you said he has
to do well there's a lot of people
watching him and think that this is the
year where not only could he sort of
turn the corner but he sort of has to
that that team has some talent I mean
it's not great talent but they got a
good running back they got some good
pieces on defense
the offensive line isn't great but they
need to show that he can do something
and grow and and at least take a step
towards proving he's a guy and this is
the year that he needs to do that and if
he can do that I've said this a little
bit in the offseason you know that team
is I mean it's not going to win a lot
but there's potential there to do some
some to win some games in a couple of
years if he turns out to be good because
there's some pieces there's but this is
you know there's Chris like every team
it's all about the QB and if you have a
bad QB or a quarterback that's just not
growing it stifles your entire franchise
and this is where the Rams are right now
I like I want to give you my scream
screaming hot cake of the day you got to
get ready for this Tom Brady Tom Brady
scream oh I will not scream I will I
will speak at the very level
Tom Brady is competing for his job this
season your thoughts are you nuts are
you nuts
come on did you have coffee this morning
I did you okay I'm good I had a large
Duncan iced um I'm good to go
are you having a stroke I'm not having a
stroke come on Mike what other reason is
there Oh wha
come on Chris I love you know Tom
Brady's never fighting for his job
ever never he's just he will be able to
stay at quarterback as long as he
physically can and you know I've had
personnel people across the league tell
me they think this is a year that he
will age will catch up to him but people
said oh so like five years every year he
looks like he's 25 years old it's
amazing I've never seen anything like it
okay well I think Jimmy Garoppolo there
Belichick is a very practical guy Chris
he he knows how football worzic I mean
the chances are time Brady is going to
another good two three years at least in
them but Bella seconds knows that
football is violent and it ages people
fast so he's being practical he's
keeping a good quarterback on the road
we just talked about golf and the other
situations around the league how hard it
is to find a good quarterback well the
pictures have one they seen him in
action in practice and games they like
and they likely study they like them a
lot personally so you keep a guy like
that just because you can and you can
prepare just in case something crazy
happens look Brady if it doesn't maybe
you train at a later date or you do but
you keep that insurance policy so
belcheck more than anything is a very
he's a very practical guy and that's why
he's there but Chris come on more coffee
you wore hold on look let me continue to
make my case here Mike you say good you
say that he's being practical and look I
get that even though Brady's been hurt
like once in his career one of the most
durable eyes playing that position
belcheck also likes future assets
he likes draft picks and and you would
know what the market was better than I
but it seems like he was at least the
12th overall pick that they could have
fetched for Jimmy Garoppolo maybe more
in a potential trade why why hold on to
him when that's
market for him when you can just move
Jacoby Brissette up maybe draft somebody
else I'm a huge deshaun Watson guy you
want to have a backup quarterback in
place drafted Shawn Watson and let him
sit there for a couple of years and wait
and see if Brady gets hold why why waste
an asset like that when maybe next
offseason even if he franchised him the
market might not be as robust look
that's a fair point and there are teams
that would have done that they would
have they would have made that trade and
got picks
I think the difference with Belichick is
and and I think really good franchises
think this way they obsess over that
position every franchise does but if
you're Bill Belichick and he look he
knows that he can win he's confident he
can win without Tom Brady but boy does
tom brady make it a lot easier and so
does a so does a franchise pose so if
you've got a guy that you know is good
and you've seen him and you worked with
him you're not going to get rid of that
asset easily unless someone disposed a
lot at you makes it so hard for you to
not keep them so he's going to keep
Garoppolo because he knows it's just a
guy like that is so hard to find look
around the league it's crazy there's
like ten teams those starting
quarterbacks are awful the whole roster
of quarterbacks are awful and you have a
guy who you trust and they trust him and
like him so they're not going to let him
go very easily i before let you go are
are the Ravens going to toss up a
Twitter poll and ask fans if they can
find out a Facebook poll it's crazy that
he snapchat maybe whenever the game is
crazy
I'll just say this I know we gotta go I
just I'll just say this Collin cap
whatever there are a lot of people have
different opinions about him as a player
and opinions about him off the field to
me I said this before what he's doing
off the field is heroic and brave and
important and on the field he is still a
really good player that's my opinion
I've seen him play we're talking about
the Patriots I covered a game
I think it was last season where he was
he played belcheck defense with almost
nothing around him and kept them in the
game almost single-handedly Caprica so
I've seen him perform at a high level he
still can and Ravens don't sign in there
fool they're fools
he's a perfect place that's a perfect
place for him and they're gonna there
they're thinking about it but I don't
know if they're going to do because the
owner sounds like he's like we just
talked about he's doing like snapchat
polls so when you start to do that stuff
you don't sound like you're serious and
doing it but if they do sign in to be
one of the smarter signings of the
offseason because they need their
backups Brian mallet is trash their
backup situation is garbage and you
bring in a Kaepernick you have a really
good backup and someone that can in some
ways be even better than the starter so
it's a smart move that they do it I
don't know if they're going to do it
though
saying the Kaepernick has been
blackballed it implies a collected
conversation or collective conversation
amongst NFL owners about this do you
believe that there's been that type of
collective conversation where people
have said you know that this guy did
what he did and we're not going to
welcome him back well I don't think if
you're first of all I do think he's
being blackballed but also Chris the
owners and they're smarter than that
they wouldn't necessarily like sent out
a note or talked about it they know that
that will be collusion they know that
that would that would be really dumb not
that there aren't dumb owners there are
but I don't think they will go that far
I think there's just a collective sort
of non spoken belief that if we signed
this guy he's trouble we don't like what
he did so there's a collective non
spoken believe we're just going to stay
away from them I just say I don't think
it's I think owners have done this in
the past with with other issues and it's
not crazy and I think that's what's
happening here but I do think I think
he's being blackballed by the league I
don't think there's any question about
it to me hey always great to talk to you
Mike I appreciate the time
so I want you to live long and prosper
gated Mike Freeman thank you Mike the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience